du coup je regarde les photos des
championnats du monde de l'année
dernière pour me remettre en situation
de l'ambiance de la motivation tout ce
qu'il faut Fanny cauchoisne se met en
condition cette cycliste mortazienne de
21 ans va participer cette semaine au
championnat du monde de cyclisme sur
piste 2022 au vélo tourne national de 50
ans en Yvelines spécialiste de la course
au point la 13e mondiale va courir sous
les couleurs du Laos un choix de cœur
mon arrière-grand-mère est là au ciel et
elle est venue vivre en France après et
j'ai beaucoup d'attaches pour la famille
et je voulais représenter les couleurs
de mes origines avec le Laos depuis
officiellement deux ans fanny a déjà
participé à plusieurs compétitions dont
les championnats asiatiques en juin
dernier une carrière internationale qui
se fait loin de l'équipe de France je
n'ai jamais été contacté par l'équipe de
France et comme j'arrivais à un âge où
il fallait que je décide si vraiment je
voulais faire du haut niveau ou pas j'ai
fait le choix de représenter Laos lors
de ces Championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste 2022 ne se sentira pas
dépaysés la jeune athlète s’entraîne
régulièrement sur les créneaux tout
public dans la structure située à
quelques kilomètres de chez elle ici la
sportive à ses repères je pense que
c'est un légère avantage par rapport à
d'autres nations qui ne l'ont jamais vu
ou moins vu c'est vrai que moi je
m'entraîne quasiment tous les jours ici
donc oui je pense que ça peut être un
avantage par rapport à certaines
personnes pendant ce rendez-vous est
Vinois la piste selon représentante de
son pays partagera son box avec l'équipe
d'Algérie à domicile à l'oracle de
briller devant son public en finissant
le plus haut possible sa course est
programmée ce dimanche 16 octobre pour
le moment c'est comme si c'était encore
dans une semaine et il faut pas trop y
penser pour pas stresser
après ces championnats du monde finir
encore des rêves plein la tête la tête
de haut niveau veut viser le titre JO de
Los Angeles en 208 et également une
participation aux Jeux olympiques de
Paris en 2024 un événement qui se
déroulera dans un vélo de route qu'elle
connaît si bien